it's crazy because I've been going to
the Bay a lot lately and you always like
I feel like you're kind of like one of
the um like unsung heroes of your area
like you know what I'm saying in terms
of like
just like you got legendary records bro
you got like a lot of your peers
respects like
do you feel like um getting like
incarcerated
did it was it kind of like a necessary
evil for you to kind of like really get
back focused the right way on the music
[ __ ]
yeah kinda but
I mean when you go to when you go to pre
when you go to jail or whatever and you
rap
gel always kind of been good for rappers
right with getting released yeah when
boozy got out he was getting stupid back
so it's like when I was in there I was
just planning for my release the whole
time you've been playing it for
everything that I'm gonna do when I get
out like how I'm a better myself with my
music and just life period you feel me
and just be on some some grown [ __ ]
for real something a little a different
Delo but the same deal you feel me